a team of American scientists have been
approved to try and regenerate the
brains of people who have been declared
brain dead I guess if it works it
changes the definition of brain wood
which had been irreversible loss of
function but if it turns out to be
curable then the patients were never
irreversible in the first place
being dead there's technology dependent
even not having a heart isn't death if
you're on the surgeons table and if the
question is if this would actually help
the person and assuming it works if the
regenerated brain is actually that of a
new person missing many of the memories
and information stored by the original
brain memories personality functions
might be scrambled lost or replaced with
newly grown tissue
the new person might have a life worth
living and enjoying but they could be
said to have benefited in the same way
that a child benefits from being born
into the world if there is limited or no
mental continuation of their old selves
then the original person won't benefit
they are now truly dead since their body
and brain have become someone new it is
the relationship between our physical
selves and who we are how much of your
body can you lose before you are no
longer you the research team at the
heart of the study may make progress or
they may have just been trying to raise
funds for a sci-fi movie but eventually
science and medicine will move in the
direction of reviving more people and
saving more lives I wonder what it will
look like when instead of saving lives
we start making older ones